le golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines est entré dans une nouvelle
dimension et c'est ryder cup 2018 sa
tribune de 6800 places installé au
départ du trou numéro a marqué
l'histoire de la compétition en devenant
la plus grande infrastructure jamais
construite pour une ryder cup des
frissons des frissons et des fruits sans
un vrai stade de sport un vrai stade de
foot de basket de le stade de france de
golf c'est vraiment impressionnant
c'est grand déjà et c'est grandiose
l'ambiance est géniale il ya énormément
nombre il y à des lieux robe qui courent
d'un côté des usa et de l'autre est un
oui c'est grandiose
voilà on peut pas dire que ça soit pas
vous c'est un grand succès français la
tribune ensoleillé ça veut tout dire ça
fait un peu la france et la zone du roi
soleil on n'est pas loin de versailles
le parcours a également été plébiscité
par les supporters et les joueurs des
deux camps préparé pendant plus de deux
ans avant le début de la compétition
pour un coût de 7,5 millions d'euros qui
est aujourd'hui considéré comme l'un des
meilleurs au monde où tant de travail
décent et des sacrifices les voir que
voilà il s'est bien passé l'image que la
france a donné le rôle national à venir
les monédières s'expliquer c'est super
c'est super comptait six très fiers te
fait d'aimer cqib et voilà comment s'est
passé le golf national va maintenant
retrouver une activité plus
classiquement les prochains mois avant
d'organiser une nouvelle compétition
planétaire dans six ans les jeux
olympiques de 2024